before we tuck into this I just want to
make a quick note about notation
actually you remember we've been talking
about three equations of motion right
three equations of motion refer to where
you are how fast you're going and how
fast you're changing how fast you're
going right so we call them displacement
velocity and acceleration now in much
the same way as I don't like it when we
use the notation y dash and white double
dash because it's a it's easy to get it
wrong and it's not as meaningful as do
you want yes or D spent Y DX squared in
a similar kind of way I try to avoid
using X dot and X double dot okay
I'm telling you them because you need to
be able to interpret them and read them
but I'm gonna recommend against you
actually using them in your own work and
here's why I'm number one they all look
the same
okay and let's face it you know when
you're in hurry and you just put a dot
there if you don't have a really good
pen the dot will just disappear right
and you don't want to mix up the
equations of motion okay secondly the
sitter's actually starting just eat your
food secondly just like before X dot X
double dot they don't carry much meaning
with them apart from differentiate again
thirdly most importantly variable when
you're talking about velocity as V and
acceleration and a not only of those
sort of common-sense letters to put on
those when we get to three in a mission
later on they use these exclusively to
really talk about V and they only talk
about a and they stop talking about Nick
stop next up a lot okay the reasons that
will become a little clearer later so
don't worry about that for now but
that's why you'll see I'm gonna use
these I'm gonna use age